-Our first guest tonight
is a Grammy-nominated singer,
songwriter, actress,
and one of the biggest
superstars on the planet.
She recently released
her first live album,
"Attention: Miley Live."
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Miley Cyrus,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Thank you.
-So happy to have you here.
-Thank you for having me.
Hello, everyone.
Good to see you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is -- This is very --
A live album is very exciting.
And there you go, right here.
-Yeah.
-And I would imagine one of
the coolest things about it
is picking the songs.
-Yes.
-And I'm wondering,
are they the songs
you most like to sing
or the ones you feel like
your fans most like to hear?
-I let my fans
create this set list,
because it's been two years
since we've celebrated
live music together.
To be honest,
I'm still getting used to
coming out of this cocoon
that we've all been in
for the last couple of years.
I think a lot of us
have been struggling
with anxiety and fear
and socially
just getting used to
connecting with each other
again.
So I thought it would bring
some hope and joy
and also just make me feel
more comfortable
knowing that my fans are happy
and knowing that I'm able
to express to them
how much I've missed them
over the last two years.
-I think that's the way
a lot of live performers I know
felt.
Did you have anxiety
about going back onstage
for the first time after?
-Yes.
I have anxiety right now,
to be honest with everyone.
-Well, we're gonna
get through that.
-You know?
And I think a lot of us
have been struggling with that,
just because integrating
into a world
that felt very familiar
but now feels new.
I'm really excited,
'cause Happy Hippie,
my foundation,
has partnered
with my longtime therapist
for Change Your Brain,
Change Your Life,
trying to help with everybody,
get used to this new normal
and seeing everyone
with masks on.
And it's hard to see
my fans sing along,
because a lot of them
are wearing masks,
so I can't tell if they
hate it or hate me.
I think you guys hate me,
or I can't tell.
-No, I don't think they do.
-Alright.
They're smiling under there.
Alright.
-You mentioned Happy Hippie.
This has been
quite a few years now
that you've had this foundation.
-Yes.
-And what was --
In the beginning,
what was it that you were seeing
that most needed attention?
-I've felt so fortunate
in my life.
I've had parents
that really support me
in all my decisions
and all my evolutions.
And I've really been
experimental
when it comes to my identity,
my sexuality.
And I really feel
that I've had
a family that's been
really supportive,
and I know that that isn't
the case for everyone.
And so I wanted to kind of
just fight that injustice.
And I think everyone
deserves the freedom
to express themselves
and no matter how they identify.
So that's very important
because again,
everything, I think, comes
from a place of authenticity
to myself first,
because it's hard to relate
if you don't feel you identify
with that same struggle.
So even though I've had
a different experience,
I identify with that.
-Well, that's great.
And it's really sweet that
you're doing that for people.
-I love it. It fulfills me.
-Feeling heard is, I think,
the most important thing for
kids who are going through that.
-Just letting people know
that you care
and that you support them.
And I think that's, again,
with the "Attention" live album,
that's one thing
that I just wanted to do,
is really let my fans know
how appreciative I am
of their loyalty.
They are the only reason
why I live the life that I live,
and I know that.
There's not one time
that I get into my bed at night
or drive myself to work
in my car
that I don't think about,
my purpose comes
so much from my fans.
And I think we share
that same bond.
I think a lot of what I'm doing
inspires them;
what they're doing inspires me;
and it's just amazing.
-That's great.
You did a great --
For your fans
and for maybe people
who already were familiar
with you,
you had a great NBC
live New Year's Eve special
last year.
You just announced today
you're going to do it next year.
-Yeah.
-You did it with Pete Davidson.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-You and Pete had a lovely time
together, it seemed.
-Yeah. You know, I'm a very --
I'm kind of a "go with the flow"
kind of person.
But, this, now it seems like
I kind of know what I'm doing
on New Year's forever.
-That's really nice!
-Which I like.
Because I need boundaries.
Someone told me one time,
it's not about
just having boundaries,
it's about just having bumpers.
Just when you start to veer,
that you have something
to bounce off of it.
So I know that I have to
keep my act together enough
to make it to New Year's.
-Yeah.
-And that NBC will actually
allow me to be on television
because there was a couple years
there where it was dicey.
-Yeah.
-Live TV.
I wasn't asked to do
a lot of live TV.
[ Laughter ]
-That's true.
You -- But I will say --
-You let me on here.
-You had -- Yeah, I mean,
you had "SNL."
You did some "SNL."
-"SNL" is a free-for-all,
which is why
me and Lorne Michaels...
Lorne has been my hero
since the first time I did "SNL"
when I was 18.
-Yeah.
-I'm gonna be 30
by the time
we're doing New Year's.
So I've been working with him
for the last 12 years,
and I feel like I've had
this really --
I don't know if anyone's
gotten to have the experience
that I'm having
of taking Producing 101
from literally
the greatest of all time.
-Yeah, he knows what he's doing.
And you're somebody he would be
drawn to naturally,
because you are --
-I'll do anything,
and I'll make an ass of myself.
-There you go.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I was gonna say
you're talented.
-Thank you.
-You're professional.
But you also --
you present to an audience,
which I think especially
he likes on "SNL."
There's some danger to you,
and yet it's not --
but you're not dangerous the way
you prepare for your art.
-No.
-And so that's the thing
that he doesn't care for.
But I think
if you can give that energy out,
which I feel like
you do such a nice job with.
-I think you have to.
If you're gonna do
a show like "SNL,"
if you're going to perform live,
by having structure,
you actually give yourself
an environment to play in,
because without setting that
environment of a safe place,
it actually gives you
this more --
I guess, more confidence
to be able to improv.
I mean, Pete, also, if we're
talking about unreliable,
I didn't know really
what was gonna happen.
He kept joking
about not showing up.
But, you know, like,
truth to every joke,
that's what makes it funny.
-Yeah.
-So I got very nervous
by, like, the 15th time
he joked about
not actually showing up.
But he showed up, and
he did an incredible job.
And the professionalism between
Lorne, Pete, our crew, and
our guests is the only reason
why we had a New Year show,
because we were really
fighting against COVID.
And at that point,
it was when we were having
a big surge
towards the end of the year.
And we also wanted to make sure
it was the right thing to do,
to continue to have the show.
So we did what we could,
which was, you know,
a very minimal audience.
We had, at first, said,
you know,
10,000 of my closest friends.
I barely have 10 friends.
But we were gonna cast 10,000
very cool-looking "Miley people"
that would look like
I had cool friends.
And then we end up having
actually just
my real friends there,
between me and Pete
and my family.
And we did everything
that we could
to make sure everybody was safe,
but they could still celebrate.
'Cause it felt like,
at the end of that year,
it was something
that everyone really needed.
It's something
that happens every year.
And to break that tradition,
I think,
could have caused
even more of a panic.
So we did it
as safely as possible.
-You've got a little bit less,
I guess, than seven months.
Do you start thinking
about next year now,
or this coming year?
-I just started
the conversation,
and it started, you know,
with all the great advice
that he's been given from,
whether it's Paul McCartney
or Paul Simon.
Lorne knows more Pauls
than anyone I've ever known.
-He knows all the best Pauls.
-Do you have a Lorne?
Do you do
a Lorne impression yet?
-I-I don't know
if I do my impression so much
as more like he's just always
kind of looking at me like this,
but I know I'm gonna do
whatever he says anyway.
-Yeah.
-Like, he's looking like,
"Yeah, Miley, that's
definitely gonna happen."
But then I know someone's
gonna call me
and go, "Lorne doesn't think
it's the best idea."
-Oh, okay.
-Yeah.
-I have more questions for you.
Mind sticking around?
-For sure.
-We'll be right back
with more from Miley Cyrus,
everybody.